I believe I read that sometimes you feel
in at different acting classes and you
help instruct was all right there's a
friend of mine who had a school in
Hollywood Josh
sands really great guy I met him at a
film festival and I met him at a film
festival and he came and helped me on
several short films and he had a school
where he was trying to help actors who
just got off the bus you know learn what
they needed to learn in order to sort of
start moving forward in Hollywood and he
asked me to teach a couple of his
classes and I did and it was fun I I
learned a lot from teaching you learn
what you know and then you also learn
what others don't know and I think from
the classes what I took from it is that
you have two types of actors ones who
want to be and others who want to be
Gary Oldman Sally Field yeah Sally Field
I worked with Sally Field she's
wonderful that was one of those moments
when I was on the set of brothers and
sisters like I knew she was on the show
but when we had our scene together I was
like oh man
and it's always very difficult because
you know they're seasoned actors and the
sort of level that we're at and sort of
the approach that we have towards the
material is always different but I was
so nervous around Sally Field she was
she was great though she was just
professional and sweet and but back to
the initial thing is that yes there
you're either going to want to be or
you're going to want to be a Sally Field
I think I want to be a Sally Field so if
you were to give advice to that class to
some of the students that were eager to
have a 20 year career and not just sort
of an instant hit and and then maybe
fade away what would you tell them well
you can tell the difference by those who
put in the work and those who don't
those who commit to the material and
those who don't
that's how you can tell who is going to
be who and you can't really tell either
of them anything because it's rich
successful and famous so Who am I to say
no you can't be and if you want to be
one go for it you know I just tried to
be
encouraging like edward james olmos has
been to me encouraging if you want to be
a celebrity and that's sort of what you
want to do then it goes back to what my
agent said no you're casting no your
desires know what your strengths are and
then pursue that so if you want to be a
celebrity silly so if you want to be a
celebrity you know don't take acting
classes just go to parties and hang out
with some really cool people and you
know look at some agents look good look
hot like but if you want to be a serious
actor definitely take classes I love
improv myself there's some great coaches
in this town and do theater theater is
the best way for an actor to discipline
themselves and like I said when you're
on stage it is your moment and also take
those auditions as that moment onstage I
think that will definitely help anyone
coming into the Hollywood but the best
thing for anyone wanting to get to
Hollywood is that I'll quote Betty Davis
on Johnny Carson when he asked her the
same question he said what do you say to
any young actress who wants to get to
Hollywood
you